It's cool stuff. You'd love
it. I'm fascinated by wolves.
I think wolves to me are probably the
most interesting animal in the wild.
Can't candidates man,
while dogs of all kind are unbelievable.
They're so at the top of
their respective food chain.
Yeah. We have a, a lot of coyotes around
here and basically they're little wolves,
the little sneaky wolves,
but a real wolves like wolves
in Yellowstone wolves in
the northwest area of the
United States.
Though there they have got to be some of
the most majestic animals cause hastick
they are there, they operate together
always yes. To these packs. Yep. You know,
so there's some sort of weird
kind of communication and,
and, and what's amazing is like the social
dynamic, like within the pack, you know,
the hierarchy and then on a hunt
like you go left, I go right.
But without any verbal communication,
right.
And then coming together and making a
killer. I mean it's mind blowing stuff.
You know,
you talk about not understanding wildlife,
we don't understand how they do that.
Right, right. We don't understand
what kind of communications going on.
Do you think there's some sort of
like telepathic or is it just a facial
recognition?
Recognizing cues and patterns that
they've established before of they see an
animal,
they note a flank it.
I definitely believe it's that.
Like I definitely believe there is an
intrinsic understanding of you go left,
I go right. You know, facial
recognition, you know, your,
your expression tells me to do something
your dominant. I'm, I'm passive, you know,
learning that way. But I also think
there's something more than that.
Whether it's telepathic, whether it's
a low frequency sound that we're,
it's not audible to us.
I have no idea.
But I do think it's more
than just visual cues. Yeah.
That's where the,
apparently the myth of the Werewolf
comes from is that wolves are so smart.
They think that wolf and a person,
we're like combined together.
I don't believe that per se, but I can see
how that came up. You know what I mean?
It's totally, there's so smart. African
wild dogs are the same. Like they,
they hunt in these huge packs.
They go over these massive areas and then
they'll push a single animal into one
area to make the kill. And they're
not big animals there. Again,
like a coyote size, and they'll take down,
you know, a kudu or some huge antelope.
I mean, it's, it's incredible.
Well,
African wild dogs are so cool looking to,
with those black spots or yellow
and all the stunning, they just,
they look angry.
Yeah. Okay. You know, there's, I think
they're, they're my favorite of the key.
Like you love wolves.
I love African wild dogs.
I just think they're so beautiful and
majestic and unusual and they're just such
a cool animal.
Correct
me if I'm wrong, but I think all of
them come from the United States.
I think all of them originally came from
North America. Like I think [inaudible].
Yeah. All candidates came from North
America. I think that's Coyote America.
The gentleman who had been on the
podcast before, what is his name,
is escaping me right now. Uh,
but he, he wrote about it.
Huh? About, you know, all the various
jackals and Flores. Dan Flores.
That's it. He's, that is fascinating book.
Yeah. I'm going to write it down. Yeah,
I'd love to read it. Great. And I did
a podcast with him, uh, years ago.
That's excellent too.
And he has all sorts of crazy
insight as to native American,
North American animals that went
somewhere else, like a horses,
like horses were native to North America,
but they weren't here when the
European settlers came. They had,
they went extinct, but they
had been taken. They had
the, there were other places,
like apparently wild horses from Europe,
all originated from North America and
we're taking over and then another wow
from whatever.
And then when extinct here and then were
reintroduced with the European settlers.
Huh. That's interesting. Crazy. Yeah. And
that's the thing,
like with what I do looking for extinct
animals are proof that they're still out
there is like,
there are so many stories like that.
I didn't know that one in specific,
America's very well covered with eyeballs.
But what's to say there isn't some
remnant small population somewhere in the
middle of nowhere that nobody has found
these horses that have been untouched by
human beings for millennia. Right. And
that's, that's what I, that's what I do.
That's what drives me.
Right? Find this pocket,
find this animal that's been hiding
out undetected for thousands of years.